so these again are the going to be the
standings
for
the remainder of this tournament
an hour 20 to go
to decide who wins one bitcoin
top three get some money those are the
payouts
for the agad mater cake defy christmas
arena
6213 in there there are restrictions
this time around you have to have 50 or
more rated games you have to be rated 2
000 or more in bullet
and there is no chat room
all right here we go
let's see how it goes
carlson back 16 from nakamura
are we gonna get that pairing in round
one no
what is f3 about was that a mouse slit
oh he's playing ridiculous for real
wow for a
for one bitcoin
f3 king f2
oh
man way to take this one serious
wow
[Music]
i mean
it's not it's not so bad in this current
position it is under control on d4 the
knight is under control with the pawn
snug like a bug in a rug on f2
no problems
uh
some some crazy way to open things up
i'm not sure that that's
helping if it comes to an ending if the
queens are off then
this is exactly where you would want the
king so maybe maybe h4
h4 is in there
you could maybe do that because you
could take with the queen
okay this queen is a little pesky here
there you have to watch out for some
tricks on this square though alright so
some security
this is a wizard right here the queen is
a wizard
look at look at her
you can't kick me off d4 and i'm seeing
every which way
rob is in the tank
open file under control
ready to double up on the
on the only open file knight on f4 next
up maybe this because there isn't a
knight h5 this knight is trapped
maybe had to tend to the threat on the
rook first
oh wow
that was a quick move right there
an in-betweener
this is covered this night is amazing
how do we how do we get in here
oh so slick giving up that beautiful
knight on f4
crushing this queen is out of play
carlson takes that where are we at in
the standings
it's at 68 now no it hasn't been updated
oh what is the story with this he's
going with f6 king f7
the standings weren't updated
oh
what's the story there
didn't he begin with 60 68
okay they were updated i'm seeing in the
chat all right get nervous there
okay this is
is this gonna be a problem okay he's
giving up a pawn to get rid of that
killer bishop
why is he playing like this
okay once more
just like in the other game the queen
taking up a big post on
what is that queen's four call it
pawn controls the knight you really
don't want to do anything with the pawn
on f6 giving up squares
oh man
why is the doctor playing like this man
this is a 2882 player
he did uh bank some material there
can he can he hold this one
it's not fun
he's grabbing another pawn
he's uh all huddled up here
how do you how do you improve
this pawn could be taken
can it not oh okay if if
maybe he get this one right here
okay the knights in the center can can
this knight do something magical
okay and this this i feel like is a
possible fortress
because there there's perfect
coordination here
yeah you have to get going with the
passer
look at this is this is
wow
he may he may go on to win this one
get out of my house he says
careful now
another check
repetition no repetition game continues
he's down on the clock
he's blocking
these guys gonna get rolling
the king is boxed out
this is crazy
oh
oh yeah
you missed that the bishop recapture
would check okay he goes down
nakamura okay they have been updated he
has 72 with fire it's just taking a
little bit to update
he's been extinguished he's playing
against
oh man i did not expect this
for
for such a big event
for one bitcoin
he's going with this f6 f3 stuff
unbelievable
okay
you never know he's he's a box of
chocolates player
ah man all right i mean this is this is
a good position
now
in betweeners he's up upon superior
minor piece
this is dubov
opponent dubob
this knight is completely dominated
fianchettoed night
tough day at the office
boom boom nope he's going to break down
the king's side like this
this night is pretty much toast
yeah perfect coordination here
everything's covered
king looking to hunt
check
king enters
we don't care about doubled pawns we
have an extra guy
an hour 12 to go
all right back to tournament he has a w
there nakamura has a
a draw
and another draw
um oh big game here he's doing this
against ali reza too
all right
holy reza doing something as i looked
away real quick what was that
all right i could two could play this
game is that what he's saying this looks
very normal now
he castled by hand doesn't want to see
knight g4
opposite sides
castling by hand
okay sacrifices on h3 doesn't want that
some security there open file
i guess when you're 3100 plus you could
do whatever you want
that's all
so he's okay with this giving up a pawn
black giving up a pawn to get some
pressure on the g file
it's more about open lines
sharp position
okay maybe this one soon
what are we doing here it looks like the
exchange
getting the exchange
black is getting the exchange soon
problem on g2
king goes towards the center
look at this tension i've never seen a
position like this
wow i've seen that in the center
one way or the other
but not in this
look at that with the queen still on
there's still a lot of fireworks
everywhere
trying to get at maybe the b5 square
okay b5 pulled this away
bishop or a queen on b5 looking to enter
this is covered this is the only
sensitive point in white's camp the
black king doesn't know where he wants
to go he's way down on the clock 36
seconds
continues forward with the pawn for what
reason here
can't make sense of that one maybe he
wanted knight here
into that square
a sacrifice where we at with the
imbalance two pawns versus a rook in
bounds
black would love a queen exchange
still have to make good good moves here
ali reza is so fast he only needs he
only needs five seconds
he'll take as an in-betweener now queen
takes queen here
he's taking the bishop
queen in the corner only 13 seconds
for ali reza
queen is a hit queen is hit
knight is hit pressure on the pawn
trying to get here and then here
it's on the rook but it's defended
check here
you get this rook
what did i miss there i missed something
oh he's getting this one the rook is
down ali reza's down
okay
where are we at here 74. they're not
updating straightaway there we go
76 okay he's continuing on this f3 king
f2 path
okay
this is a this is a pretty decent
structure
normally i believe the way to try and
break this down is to have one of these
two at least contribute when it's only
these two
you have
it seems like you you
white's able to buy some time you can't
take there's a pin here
you're able to buy some time
to you know complete your development
that's defended
he's gonna have to work around a pesky
knight on b4
you get this square this square the
white pieces find really good squares
what is uh what's black considering here
oh
back home
maybe the problem was knight takes pawn
queen takes knight
there's a pin
these night jumps were nearby maybe you
don't even take the rookie yeah
this bishop is awesome
if knight here then you would take
because it's a free rook
but this is the super glue of the
position so
maybe a chop and then you start bolting
with this guy
down on the clock ninja
64
from serbia
minute 26 for
carlson
problem with this rook on e5
knight f4
okay
maybe the king steps back up
no fear of uh some pin or knight on f6
anymore how we recapturing first of all
you have to go with the queen
well that's fancy
yeah
here there's this
and then that one
but carlson is up a piece no he's not up
a piece what am i talking about he's
down a pawn that was a slick sequence
right there by ninja
there's still some space over here a
knight on d4 is going to be pretty
strong now the king enters and the king
will enter as well on d4
this tension remains if black ever bites
there'd be a two to one majority
and he has control he's going to get
some activity for the rook
bishop here next up
have to break this down
mmm don't let the king enter
tough to make progress here bishop takes
pawn the rookout sax some activity
okay probably come back over
okay this is this is tough to break down
though
maybe he's maybe he's gonna try for
something like that
he has he has many ways to do it he's
gonna get this one
huge time edge
yeah this should be
an easy flag
yeah he can afford to simplify he might
even be winning this
yeah the pawn is a runner probably
flicking that one
if he wants to he's gonna take this one
okay down on time he goes nakamura not
having the greatest run here
i don't think he's won a game yet
um maybe one game since we uh
since the start of this part two
nakamura
excuse me carlson has 76 excuse me 80
with fire he's 14 back
14 back with fire still an hour four to
go
so how we how are we dealing with
this trio of pawns
let's see
how to get it the king
let's keep it closed
i need time to complete development
problem on d4
maybe if takes you push
yeah
or excuse me there's something something
would happen on this square g6 so
shut things down offer a queen exchange
maybe some space looking for a break
next
c5 c5 on board
keeps the tension for the moment
knight on d4 eventually will be very
strong
wants a light square bishop exchange
we'll get that
this night is better
this night right here is annoying though
hang on
and this is a really annoying night now
the queen has to babysit
there might be some accident happening
here oh i like this transfer oh i like
the black knight better watch out for
these tricks
could have some fancy mate
careful now
this is not a fun position for the rook
not a fun position for white
there's still a pawn break here the king
is going to hide on this side
well this unusual
this is maybe an
interesting strategy
by carlson going with these moves here
just getting some unusual position
and forcing your opponent to to think
how do i break this nonsense down
so far it's only been broken down once
okay
probably don't even demote the night
capture no you are demoting the knight
okay now this is nearby
but then this and then maybe the queen
enters okay queen takes pawn queen
exchange
pressure on the night are there any
night checks not yet these guys
definitely don't want to be here anymore
do we get them over now we get them over
now only 26 for pragnanda
rook is in a pin next up is this you
have to block
the knight or the or the rook there's
going to be an accident happening soon
on g2
22 seconds left
he doesn't care about the queen
he's gonna have some mate
with two rooks and a night
take with the knight of the pawn
he's backing off i'm gonna save my queen
for a second
he'll hide over here
he'll zigzag his way to safety
oh just right there
watch out for this check
the night check
right here check
that one was missed
the rook block
only one second to 42 an easy flag
down on time where are we at in the
standings
carlson with 84 and fire only 12 back
ali reza still everybody's getting this
treatment doesn't matter who you are
f3 king f2 treatment
knight was pinned no knight takes queen
once more this knight is under control
how cozy though is this king with the
queen still on
approaching an hour left
oh boy
this is this is gonna be trouble
there's too much energy here look at
this bishop
doesn't uh doesn't even need to move to
be a contributor there's going to be a
sacrifice
yeah this this one's broken down
i don't know how you save this one
okay
i'm gonna use this pawn as a shield
he says and now rook here incoming
i think the doctor's going
down oh man look at look at oh look at
everything here
take the knight there's a queen check
he's going to resign here
okay doctor goes down
99 for nakamura alireza 87 the doctor 84
extinguished cake in space a berserk
game
no berserk back
okay
jordan van forest
one of carlson's seconds for the
championship
the world
championship one of his seconds for this
for this arena
he's so fast
cake in space
oh boy
knight's ready to arrive on this square
one way or the other it's getting into
d6
dark square weaknesses
for carlson
i think you have to be prepared to give
up the exchange nope doesn't want
doesn't want to give that up
get rid of the light square bishops
this is secure
i don't think you would mind it you have
to take with the rook
or excuse me this knight if rook takes
bishop otherwise that's going to be
painful
okay
this bishop is really good 32 seconds
for white
dark square weaknesses there was a mate
on g7 light square bishops off
and get the queens off don't step up
here
okay
fancy move there
oh look at that look how quick that was
recognized
it's not easy
white cannot be better white cannot be
worse here white
has an excellent position
a winning position maybe
no
how do you stop this guy first of all
this one's gonna be hunted this rook is
gonna go back
oh we have this check maybe no this pawn
was too fast also promoting with check
this this should be a flag
keep the rooks on
let's see the flag
it's in the tank here
why'd he go with that path a draw on
board
okay
103 94 88 85 for the doctor who does not
have fire
jagalco next
f3
king f2
i'm surprised that he uh he allowed a
rook exchange
maybe he didn't want to do that to a
second
that's that's what it must have been
i can't do that
all right
this is the this is the big home for
nearly every white piece d4
56 minutes to go
i think if this maybe you take with the
pawn
so that you have a way to
break down
white's position you can look forward to
a d4 break there's
maybe something is going to happen on c2
this this rook c2 is not there because
you're on the queen
wow
okay that was a cool sequence
you are going to get the queen
a rook and
bishop versus queen and pawn
super strong knight
might be an accident happening here
no knight f4
okay rook is hit
where's the rook go
out of the pin
oh boy
can you get away with taking this i
guess there's going to be going to be a
fork
simplifying
getting one rook off is usually a good
a very good thing
it's harder for white to now coordinate
with the pieces
tough to tame the queen there is a night
check on e1 i don't know if it really
goes anywhere more simplification
knight on f4
oh boy
black is simply mopping up all these
pawns
37 seconds is plenty of time for jagalka
to convert this
queen in three pawns
versus a rook and bishop
wants to keep this bishop here
how do you how do you improve this
doesn't do really a whole lot
this is too dangerous
too dangerous upon the past a pawn
check here check there pawn continues to
march
just looking at some checks there's
nothing fancy here maybe a skewer
that wouldn't even be a win
the wrong colored
wrong colored bishop there goes the rook
down he goes
man
ooh
nakamura with a couple of goose eggs in
there ali reza as well 85 for the doctor
cone vlad
artemyev is having a nice run
i think he only has one loss in the
event
the chess experience
played against carlson i believe
oh yeah they they did play in the
in the first part of this tournament
it didn't uh
didn't count for the tournament though
that uh last game loss
all right what do we do here problem on
b2
all right backward pawn
looking to jump in here next there is a
check on c5 maybe
doesn't want to give up that dark square
bishop it's the better bishop
rather give up the light square bishop
than the dark
knight retreats bishop on a nice
diagonal this is secure
swiping the knight he wants that c5
square oh he wants the c4 square
pile up on the weak link a knight jump
on b6 this is excellent for white these
pawns
dominate the night
22 moves in
only 52 minutes remaining this event
okay
in betweener knight takes bishop you
take with check and then recapture
yeah this there's the fork that's
probably still good but
sim
the best is to kick the knight okay he
gets that one where is he at rebecca
harris is
flying in there with 88
103 where's the doctor
is that 85
it should be 87
hasn't updated yet
let us see
castling once more by hand
daniel dubov
okay
some space
we connecting nights or what
is that a problem
okay get ready for some sharp play
oh man
gotta get rid of this pawn soon
hit three times defended once
this is secure
no queen entering
gets rid of that pawn
is up upon
wide open king position
saves the knight
strong post maybe looking at this square
what's wrong with this there'd be queen
takes rook there's a threat here it's
defended
carlson up on the clock
check he's secure this is secure
there are some night checks
doesn't seem to be going anywhere though
this this night check
if here then there's a fork maybe the
king would go here though
is that what he's maybe calculating
i'm not sure
he's in the tank though
i know that much under 40 a minute 32
safety
flight square
now we flush the queen away get this
rook playing soon
okay
the night there are no great discoveries
or are there
maybe the knight hops in here
uh maybe maybe then there'd be this
though
and there's a problem right here
bishop backs off wow self pin
there's a check
i'm gonna get this soon
i know the queen of the queen is
these pieces are flying everywhere
gotta give up the exchange
knight versus bishop imbalance
this is covered
just a blink you have to try some flag
wow
queen here no you're going to get mated
he has to go for the perpetual
whoa
okay no fire
how often do you see that three losses
in a row for nakamura where is
the doctor 88.
no uh smooth
road to victory here look at rob
97. oh here we go
what am i doing missing this game
carlson versus nakamura
f3 king f2
the game we've all been waiting for and
i missed the first
few moves
all right let's see
it's under oh what a big miss
what a big miss it's different when the
knight is still there because you could
recapture and defend the queen
carlson goes down in a blink
ooh
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh that one stung
that one definitely stung
you could you could
make that move when the night is still
here you're able to recapture and defend
but that knight had a different idea
wow talk about a quick kill
that's a big win
for team nakamura team tsm
uh oh
to watch out for this square
there's a check
king is ready to hide over here
carlson is in ninth
with 47 to go this is far from a runaway
that uh
rob character
is in second with fire
fm
from armenia
let's see
tough to get at the king
once more
open file here there's a
this this should be a pretty big problem
whoa what's that about
okay i didn't even see that
it's a possibility there
it should be cozy though
where is it
or is it this guy can't really move this
one would fall
ready to pile up on d2
problem on f5
do we even care about that
don't even care
some defense
might be some accident happening on this
structure
where's the queen go
queen
f4 a lot of squares taken away from the
queen looking at this oh boy
uh-oh
uh-oh
he knows there's a problem and he's not
seeing a solution
oh that's slick you get the queens off
oh
saves the day
that's how you stop mate you just get
rid of the queens black resigned
okay
who's this player
they weren't in the top uh at the start
okay nakamura has fire
he's got 116.
horrendous brilliancy has berserked i
have no idea who this is
this is this is a new account for me
horrendous brilliancy
you could take here with the bishop take
here
a rook versus a bishop in pawn in bounds
get the queens off the queens are off
strong center now it is
just in exchange
for white
knight arriving on this square soon
takes away f4 first breaks down the
center a little bit
wants to break it down further
doesn't want the f4 move to hit with a
fork you cannot take twice because of
this
maybe now you could the knight is
guarding this one
maybe a chop and then here at some point
not just yet
27 seconds for white
okay
fancy moves
fancy night don't go here there's this
one
112
this is a super piece
20 seconds
43 minutes remaining in the tournament
to watch out for skewers
good you could have you could maybe play
that one no just rick take spawn
this square is covered
you make progress
not easy
repetition
okay nakamura 116 with fire
where's the doctor 10th 90
cone vlad
started the event with two losses
only one loss after that
crest 64 next opponent
all right
let us see
there was an opportunity to take that
pawn
since the night was on e2
yeah i'm not sure who that last opponent
was
where does this knight want to be
maybe this and then put the knight here
some dark square like even if yeah like
a knight getting into that square would
be nice
you have to give up that pawn
he was eyeing up h5 there is a pin rook
takes pawn
maybe a threat maybe he could have
allowed that and then played here and
the rook would be stuck
a lot of maybes where are the brakes
no great brakes here
i don't know if you're really gaining a
whole lot with this one
hold your ground
i was gonna say queen here
that wouldn't be good
what are we doing with this guy
black isn't finding a way to break it
down just yet okay oh
ooh hang on
that knight has definitely improved oh
look at how quick
the knight has this one covered two
rooks versus a queen just like that in a
blink rook is hit some coordination
defend the pawn
this and then this
okay
we get it this guy is hit
where are the perpetuals
check first
king here maybe this
we don't take the pawn
get to the second
do we care about taking this pawn
we do
there'll be a problem there
black has to hope for perpetual looking
for mate next
you have to come back and block
check here then there's another check
buy yourself time though
it's not comfortable for the black king
you got mates how do you stop it
you don't
you don't stop queen here
pawn's in the way
a resigner coming up
clock ticker
a resigner
okay nakamura still in first 119 105 104
cone vlad cone vlad cone vlad artemiev
the doctor is out of page one
a double berserker game
gepetto
oh boy
wants to hide here bishop takes pawn
bishop check here
the light is so weakened
gonna hide
you take me he says
maybe a queen check oh boy these light
squares oh something landing here
gonna be painful
step over you get mated
these light squares
there's a check
good thing you have that one covered
probably once the queen's off oh boy
massive fork incoming you're going to
get the exchange at minimum
gets the exchange
up on the clock and position completely
gone
for team black we also have a passer
carlson resigns
nakamura 121 with fire 108 104 cone vlad
cone vlad doesn't care about that
berserk button don't forget do not sleep
on rebecca harris
narditzky is having
a super run
four wins in a row all berserks
nippo gets revenge
yeah i think i'm i'm pretty sure it's
known
carlson's opponent
last game got his revenge
nepo
nyopomnishi
another double berserk game
37 minutes remaining
can't go here to be a problem on d4
after the rick exchange
i think this knight wants to be
somewhere else
that f4 square is ideal
pressure here
it's opening up a square
bishop is improved on b3
rook e2 queen exchange
queen d2 rook rook e3
can't block now
king's gonna hide on h2
can you form a battery on the back rank
okay knight in a pin this rook is stuck
queen exchange
21 to 11 this guy is way too fast from
armenia i don't see it happening
five seconds he's he's
increasing his time lead
his time edge
three to fourteen
yep the tricky night wins
that is a win for team
black carlson down again penguin
do not forget about the penguin either
he has jumped into page one carlson is
now in twelfth
ali reza seventh seventh spot
couldn't go like this
knight c6
clever way to defend
kick the queen off of this and then
react
dark square problems this is secure now
both of these are secure
don't allow the knight to get driven
away
there's some problem here
not comfortable to defend like this oh
boy
oh boy
so fast look at how quick these moves
are oh this wasn't this was a berserk by
ali reza
i think normally he would he wouldn't do
this but he knows that carlson's in this
mode of
you know he's going with f3 f6 all day
so i'll i'll be all right he says
with uh
being back 30 seconds how do you stop
these two connected passers
there's a check
another check
look at this this is this is instructive
look at this coordination between the
rook and the knight and the king
now he could play for time
grabs the pawn yeah
olly reza let this one get away he's
probably frustrated
keep the rook
it's not it's a one king and pawn ending
how do you stop the pawn
wow
not the greatest approach right there
you will get the
holly reza is going to get this one
or not a draw
down on the clock
nakamura still in first 125
penguin with 100 and fire
i don't know
what are what are your thoughts here
with
the doctor's play
he's a
i really didn't expect this i i figured
i mean he he he plays silly like this
for
titled arenas but i didn't see this one
coming
this
nonsense play
f6f3 all day
this one's completely gone
he'll probably still win somehow
but
yeah he's he's getting into these
lost positions early
abbott 02
from
azerbaijan
okay we got a beefy center
oh this was a double berserker game
all right
under 30 for each
rook and pond versus a bishop
looking good for white
rooking two pawns versus a bishop even
better
got these squares covered by the miners
doesn't want to see knight a4 into b6
maybe also wants a square for the king
takes in the center
now some checks
he didn't block maybe the queen enters
here under 10 for white
uh he's getting the rook
carlson should be getting this one
yeah gets the queens up
look how quickly those pawns were
knocked out
okay the doctor gets that one a rare win
a rare win
120 geppetto
gepetto coming up the ranks there in
second
yoponishi
eight back with fire
eight
eight away from taking over not the
number one spot from nakamura who's held
it for basically this whole event still
30 minutes to go
pragnanda
game 2
carlson 15th
not even not even page 1.
okay
this is a nice advance
this is
making this pawn
backward for
the rest of the game
a great grip
over b3
can't get rid of this this weakness
strong night it's the only thing going
for white here
it's not fun it could be broken down
this stuff past a pawn
no bishop b5 where does this knight want
to be maybe over here
maybe c5
knight a4
c5 all right bishop says i got you under
control
black is up two pawns
okay if you take it's gonna get hunted
huh doesn't
he wants this file first
king takes straight away this rook gets
activity
get out of this the discover check
target this guy one day it's getting
broken down in the center this rook has
a responsibility
yeah this is uncomfortable for white
under a minute for black
i expect him to convert this oh this is
covered
the knight has a square but now this
rook is really active
okay so this with then this maybe
bishop is going to knife in soon
g pawn gun
that's a threat
stopped this is cozy good coordination
here
step over here
now you drop that pawn maybe
now you're on the rook there okay now
there is a square this is excellent the
bishop covers both checks from the night
this one's over carlson's going to go
down again
rook or bishop can assist in stopping
the pawn
carlson resigns rebecca harris
128 118 yaakov baby
who's yaakov baby in second
okay rebecca harris
maybe uh what's the doctor doing he's
he's just giving everybody else a chance
at this one bitcoin
oh man
i guess you have to be a
a five-time world world champion to
to understand why
why you uh
play
silly like this
for one bitcoin
he just doesn't care
i'll do what i want
wow
look at that
i don't care i'll take that pawn two
minor pieces in a pond
he's saying go ahead show me
i dare you to try and break this down
back home
coordinated nights
it's not easy it's not easy to break
this down
a queen no it's it's a queen versus two
nights and two pawns
all right one night is gone but look at
these guys
he has perfect coordination
gonna maybe drive this knight away first
but i got a new square he says
take like this are you okay with that
taking towards the center
he has a square
he has a square here
he has shelter over there
none of this
it's a dangerous night
under 55 for narditzky
sknight's going to jump around doesn't
want to see this
look at the coordination
maybe there at some point
or possibly hunt this no that pawn would
fall
okay he's giving back the exchange
bishop right here once more look at how
quick it only takes two moves all right
i'm back to coordinated he says now this
pawn starts to run a little bit one
sensitive point on g7 he's okay with a
rook exchange look at look at the
coordination here
oh that was a big mouse slip
he meant something else there not sure
what it was
no he just wasn't expecting that okay we
have another game carlson now and 20th
25 minutes to go what are the standings
129 122
120
whoa only seven point edge
crazy
only a dozen more games
nyoponishi
there's only one square there
the rook was there that'd be me
killer knight
how do we get rid of this guy
how to get rid of them
see this time and time again
this pawn the space there's a lot of
stuff you gain
black gets into the the h4 move take
away g3 you have a square on h5 for both
minor pieces primarily the knight
would coordinate really well with the
pawn
a black pawn on h4
okay anyhow what's happening on the king
side
new square produced here
in one of the games i think it was it
was against jagalka before there was a
problem
ended up losing the queen
in their first pairing
once more looking at this
c2 square knight lands in there looking
for the dark square bishop looking at
this square
knight takes e3
maybe rook c2
he's given it to think rook c2
doesn't want to take the rook and
yeah there'll be a problem there
it's going to be a problem no matter how
you slice it this knight covers this
square
this and then that
carlson's in the tank
okay
well
that's not a fun move to make
not at all
under a minute
hmm
oh man
the knight cannot move
could be me
he's getting this piece out of nowhere
where is he
where is he
okay we're gonna have a queen exchange
that took a lot of time though to spot
that rook c4 move
four pawn edge
edge
opposite colored bishops though opposite
color bishops
are drawn
this rook is a little stuck though
this rook is stuck
oh
tough day at the office for this rook
yeah needs this guy around as a block
hater
wow
problem here
oh he's he's gonna get this one on time
unbelievable
what a guy oh look at that
no repetition
don't allow the repetition
black timed out okay
nakamura 135 with fire 127 124 only 21
minutes to go before we figure out who
wins one bitcoin it's not going to be
carlson
rebecca harris 114. conevlad 118
a double berserk game here
carlson in the 18 spot
i wonder how
i wonder how convlad would do artemyev
if he was
a bit more berserky this is threatening
to win the night
no no squares now now there's a square
see this this is a nice setup here
i i prefer white in this position
i'm gonna clamp down
we're gonna have some dark square
strategy
soon the king may be looking to enter
as soon as the knight blocks here he's
able to do that look at how quick that's
recognized i love it
oh that was a mess
not just one pawn
okay dark squares
try and hang on to the dark squares
oh isn't it
this is a new title i believe
i think this is a i think they used to
be an fm
recent uh fm turned im
this uh i believe this player
when a keyboard was allowed
the keyboard extension they used the the
keyboard
i believe they would they would win this
like
or at least draw this
always but the keyboard is no longer
allowed so
still super fast
carlson timed out
he did take that one
super speedy
nakamura 140 with fire under 20.
the doctor
consistent
i don't even know what you call this
does it even have a name f6 f3
king f2
silly silly town variation what do we
got there
i'm not a fan of it
i want to see some real chess
[Music]
okay the knight wants this square there
is a check
didn't even want the check
i almost feel like this was a
pre-move he expected the check to land
okay he's gonna go here
watch out for the break
infernal
don't know who that is
okay b2 is covered
no breaks here for black
there's one possible break here
f4 f4 on board
two rooks versus a queen in bounds base
points cover them
step one coordinate
step two do what king wants to come over
here if he can
he's looking for a way to sneak in
maybe
i want to see queen check here he wants
to come over
he wants to this is where there's
shelter
he's uh paving the way for
yeah he's got to guard that
don't give that pawn up under 10 seconds
though
oh he snuck that one in there this is
broken down coordinate the rooks
you should take this one
time burners nearby
okay the doctor takes that one but he's
not taking the tournament that's for
sure
way too far back
nakamura 142 130
double berserker game sparta
all right
queen exchange queen exchange hunting a
light square bishop
check first
you have a square here a bishop or a
knight
this is a clumsy piece both of these
knights are very clumsy
this is the best piece for white king on
e3 secure central
blacks up a pawn though
big square here for black
nice we saw this with the pragnanda game
this pawn
both of these pawns right here
this is forever weakness on b2
nice king post
okay
these guys going to get rolling at some
point maybe this this and then have two
connected passers
knight takes pawn okay it's now balanced
so he's looking at this he wants an
outside pass pawn it seems like he's
gonna get it
these guys are running though
there's a threat
okay how we what are we doing here
knight takes pawn knight takes bishop
they should be winning for black i don't
know these guys are looking a little
dangerous
more than a little dangerous
check here oh check with the knight and
then there's this if the king goes here
oh so slick two queens on the scene
uh swipe the knight first check here
wow look at that how does this happen
now he's out of play
at the end of that all
at the end
at the end of that all
what am i saying
where's the mate there's the mate
okay
oh man 143 131 he takes that one
ali rez is in 10th
okay pregnant on to chess again
magnus
why are you doing this
the fans wanted to see some real chess
we don't get to see some real chess
a berserk by the doctor
not by pragnanda pragnanda in 10th maybe
still eyeing up one of those top three
it's not just that first prize
top three places get something
this is an uncomfortable situation
you move the night this falls you move
the queen the night falls
okay so you have to do awkward stuff
knight is under control by the bishop
maybe he wants to get the queens off and
go from there
no
no that one falls but then there's this
oh fancy fancy
this and then queen takes rook
yeah
all right now we have discoveries maybe
not just yet
this there would be that
this there would be that
this is a runner
here you take the queen
you could have the promotion
black resigned okay azar azaro 25
azaro 25 from
we don't know
okay
queens come on
king should be healthy on f2
oh i have to go here here there's a
check
an h5 want the pawn or the bishop he
wants the pawn
three to one
he's got the pawn he's got the c4 square
he wants this guy under
control this knight isn't uh
isn't going to get trapped no could
rescue him
it's the pawn back
covers c3
there is a check by the night
check here maybe
d5 square hits the rook gains control
over the file
oh
not fun
no square looking to cut off the bishop
from defending the night
wow look at how quick that's recognized
unbelievable you take here i take here
who saw that as a resource
oh
so fast
the a pawn in the crosshairs
king up
king up
bishop will be a block hater
can we hunt the pawn first control the
night he says
night here night here there'd be a fork
there's a check could take upon
king steps up looking at mate in two
oh
so fancy
check the rook would simply block now
you get this
now you're setting up discoveries
you get to take with check and then come
back just in time wow
all right the doctor takes that one 145
133
gepetto no fire top four
now gepetto right here
a berserk game
a double berserker
nakamura still in the lead
it's looking it's looking
like he's going to take it
with only 10 minutes in change to go
okay
yeah this night is a little
a little uncomfortable
being kiddoed night
okay
that square was being eyed up
what are we doing here
i don't expect the rook to move
yeah doesn't even want it
oh fancy
watch out for the mates
this is covered
mate thread okay black resigns that one
145 133 still a 12 point edge uh
it's not yet reflected there
it's not updated right away
a double berserk game rob who has
dropped back to the 16 spot been on that
page one for
quite a while
hmm pineroni i looked away at the chat
there for a second
oh pins being exploited
every which way
flush the bishop away from defending the
night
maybe you do this
and hunt the rook he's going like that
all right yep we're gonna have this
sequence
don't do this get mated
two minor pieces versus the rook
you'll rook up and over
not quite pressure on the night
okay skewers
you don't have to take either one that
situation
could hold off for to move
ah look at that
he wants to get this guy
potential targets
hmm
is there time
[Music]
is there time to do this
he's taking that one first ah he wants
this one and then here
just in time now these guys push through
take this one so the this this was the
more dangerous one because the king
could help defend it
cake in space another berserk game a
double berserk here
147 with fire
nakamura is definitely taking this one
only three more games left is the only
one with fire
up a bunch
wasn't as uh smooth the second half of
the tournament for nakamura but he is he
is taking it convincingly
problem on d6
it's defended
his pawn is pinned
quick resigner by cake in space
147 136
11 back no fires though
penguin with 131 and fire penguin
looking for the number two spot
that's definitely possible
penguin taking the two spot
the doctors in 12th
berserk by
this guy
the doctors berserking
okay
beautiful square
knight on e6
it's in it's in a pin
this queen is amazing best piece in the
position
counter-attack
take the knight allowed this take away
this big square from the night
you gotta watch out for these moves
though
that'd be scary
incoming queen g4 this queen's out of
play all of a sudden how did that happen
there's even this as a shot
knight takes it's a main
this this there's a mate and a few
check check checkmate
let's also check here it's dangerous for
white
queen and knight on these two
absolute monsters
it's going into a prevent babysitting g2
getting out of a pin
pressure
might be some accident happening here
soon
some accident soon
is queen making life a little bit
difficult for this rook lift
okay
problem here it's defended
smothered mate
no smothered mate
it's up a piece
pressure on the bishop
just glue him right in there he says
25 seconds for the doctor
couldn't take the rook there's a pin
centralization these guys are dangerous
the queen is still on board the king
these guys continue to march there goes
upon
good block here
no ensuing check on the
diagonal it's got that covered oh he's
defending the mate right here now watch
out for the back ranks
oh
right if this there's that
okay
coordination objectively this is winning
team black
h2 watch out for h2 it's covered now by
the queen
bishop blocks down on the clock
check
check
zigzagging checks
queen exchange
clocks
one good time burner is all that's
needed
there it is
the doctor goes down
again
three minutes in change remaining
the penguin with a wind look at that the
penguin 140 jumped up there in the
number two spot
the number two spot
there's the payouts
all right
the doctor will
finish outside of page one
what could you do
okay
we've seen this so many times
he's just all right with giving up the
queen
he's got a lot
a rook a bishop and two pawns for the
queen here
it looks like this guy's gonna get
hunted
this that that
hmm
that's a little surprising
i would have expected this put oh no
there have been a queen check
i see only now
knight right here
oh boy
gotta guard f3 f3 under control under
two minutes
double drugs double trouble
under 10.
only one game between the the doctor
nakamura nakamura
crushed it had that
trick on f4 final game of this event
still up in the air for the number two
spot
penguin wins that next game he should
take it
the number two spot
berserk by carlson
all right
what do we do on e6
cover that square
oh
this pawn right here would have been
really strong
bishop gets out of that move
this could still be really dangerous
upon on c3
some mates
get the queen over here with the pawn
here
this is a really good piece though
piece that probably wants to move at
some point to unleash these monsters
is there a good forward move by this guy
meanwhile
it's blown open here on the queen side
that's it for the tournament
zeros
the doctor is going to finish
maybe maybe
maybe not even on page two
we'll see
this one will not count for the
tournament
this last game here it is over
yeah this bishop was pinned so rook
takes pawn was a serious threat it was a
main two threat
black resigned here
okay let us see the final standings
congrats to nakamura taking first very
convincingly
with 154
penguin second
andrew tang 142 dropstone third and
those are the two those are the three
that
win these prizes right here first prize
going to nakamura one bitcoin
that's crazy
uh this is your page
page one look at coneblad
he's the highest rated
of them all
nearly 3200 finished with 136 doesn't
berserk any
let's have a look at the top 100 see how
everyone finished
min lee right here in the 10 spot
has uh
won many titled arenas rebecca harris
just outside of
page one where did the doctor finished
he finished in 14th
and i can't see the performance or the
number of games and
such
and there's page two
page three ali reza
look at all the goose eggs
in this second second part of this
tournament
finished in 23rd
tough event
there's your top 50
sixty
seventy eighty
ninety
and there you go that is your top one
hundred
seven thousand plus entered in this one
again this restriction
they wanted to make sure it went smooth
it did go smooth
very nice tournament
i'd say good games off there was a chat
room but there's no chat room just to
type it in there
all right awesome event again congrats
to nakamura for taking that one bitcoin
awesome
you